j'ai très choqué que de constater
finalement qu'on fait passer le
fanatisme avant les valeurs quoi
et à quelques semaines dans cette
émission Jean-Pierre Bernay c'est venu
donner sa version de la faire MVA ce
soir la parole est à l'accusation voici
Jacques Glassman et son avocat
Eric Dupont Moretti
tout est résumé dès le départ c'est à
dire que maintenant quand Jean Glassman
arrive dans un dans une émission de
télévision comme sur un stade il est hué
donc c'est pas pour ça que tu es venu
avec ton avec ton avocat bon alors on va
commencer par un bref rappel des faits
ensuite on va voir ce qui s'est passé
depuis un an depuis l'affaire omva et
puis on discutera de ton avenir alors au
niveau du rappel des faits en ce qui te
concerne deux questions restent en
suspens la première c'est est-ce que
même pendant un très court laps de temps
tu as été complice de la magouille j'ai
jamais été complice comme j'ai dit j'ai
relaté l'effet j'ai relaté tout ce qui
s'était passé et puis je l'ai dit à mes
dirigeants et à la presse c'est tout
donc ça veut dire que même si tu as
donné l'impression à Robert et
bourruchaga pendant un moment d'être
complice c'est une habileté de ta part
j'ai pas arrêté de leur dire qu'il
fallait pas accepter je crois que eux on
leur conscience moi j'ai la mienne ils
ont pris une décision j'en ai pris une
autre je crois que c'est chacun fait un
choix il y avait pas de chef de bande
c'était pas moi de dicter leur conduite
et je crois que j'ai fait le bon choix
ils ont fait le mauvais choix la
deuxième question qui se pose et c'est
la défense de Bernez défense qu'il a
qu'il a tenu ici c'est lui dit est-ce
que c'est trois gars enfin est-ce que
Glasman est sûr que c'était moi qui
parlais au téléphone bon avec la
discussion qui a eu après avec Georges
brouchaga c'est bon c'est ça qui m'a qui
m'a indiqué que ça pouvait être que lui
il y avait que lui qui pouvait être au
courant de de ce qu'ils ont dit et puis
ils vont quand tu as entendu beaucoup de
chaga discuter de Maradona avec le
correspondant téléphonique tu as eu la
certitude qu'il s'agissait de bernesse
je pensais que c'était lui et bon même
maintenant il y a une chose qui revient
bon j'ai eu le la chance de le
rencontrer pendant les confrontations
bon il y a
sur les stades c'est pas mieux et tu as
déclaré tu dis quand on voit Bernay
saclamer au stade Vélodrome qui fait le
tour du stade Vélodrome avec tout le
monde qui l'applaudit c'est le monde à
l'envers c'est pas fait quoi quand tu as
vu ça à la télévision surtout bon qui
qui criait bon j'ai pas craqué quoi ça
pour moi ça va tout dire quoi il dit pas
je suis pas coupleur il dit j'ai pas
craqué donc
alors toi maintenant chaque fois que tu
vas sur un terrain de de foot il y a des
banderoles il y a des colibiers on te
crie Glasman téléphone
Glassman la honte Glasman balance c'est
d'être infernal de jouer dans ces
conditions là je crois que ça a été ça a
été dur au début c'est vrai que je m'y
attendais pas tellement mais bon au fil
de l'année je crois que j'ai je me suis
mis une petite une petite carapace et
puis j'ai réussi à surmonter ça je crois
que
c'est pas les gens qui vont me faire
abandonner
j'ai très choqué que de constater
finalement qu'on fait passer le
fanatisme avant les valeurs quoi
vous en doutais pas un peu avant non je
m'en doutais pas non c'est vrai je
pensais qu'il allait avoir des jambes
bon c'est vrai des des fanatiques des
supporters de Marseille tout ça je les
comprends parce que peut-être quelque
part ils comprennent pas mais bon moi je
pense que de là à m'insulter tout ça
c'est quand même
mais il y a toujours été un peu comme ça
c'est vrai qu'à Strasbourg tu étais
rebeller contre un entraîneur qui
insultait les joueurs déjà c'est vrai
parce que il insulte des jeunes joueurs
qui étaient là pour apprendre le métier
donc c'était je crois que c'était pas
une bonne solution mais c'est pareil
j'aime pas l'étiquette de rebelle je
suis pas un rebelle je suis je suis un
mec tout à fait normal mais quand il y a
des choses qui vont pas et si je pense
que j'ai raison bah je crois que je
donne mon opinion c'est tout à fait
normal quand tu es sur un stade tu as
peur de recevoir autre chose que des que
des insultes de recevoir des projectiles
par exemple ben j'en ai déjà eu moi
jeter des pièces et puis des faux
billets c'est
c'est toute l'intelligence quoi mais bon
je vous dis je veux je veux pas juger
les gens et puis c'est c'est comme ça
c'est tout c'est un petit peu drogue
je les prends pas
il y a des fois qui sont encore pire tu
peux même pas jouer c'est ce qui s'est
passé à Nice qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
exactement bah là je crois que c'est
c'est là où ça m'a fait le plus mal je
crois que bon je m'étais préparé pendant
pratiquement trois semaines c'était le
premier match de la saison et bon ma
vertu pratiquement trois heures avant de
partir et je crois que là alors qu'on
m'avait dit que j'allais jouer qui avait
qui allais avoir des de la de la
sécurité à Nice et on me l'a on me l'a
dit 3h avant le match ça a été ça a été
terrible donc quand tu as découvert que
les dirigeants du club avaient cédé au
chantage tu t'es mis à pleurer c'est ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai que j'ai pleuré et
ça m'a ça m'a vraiment dégoûté moi je
voulais passer des au chantage bon
maintenant mes dirigeants ont pris leur
responsabilité et c'est dommage
puisqu'on voit que sur tous les autres
stades ça a été la même chose donc
j'aurais pu très bien pu jouer ce match
il y a qu'à Marseille que tu pourrais
jamais jouer quoi
bah je sais pas j'en sais rien on verra
tirer ben moi si sportivement je suis
prêt à jouer je suis prêt à jouer sur
tous les stades de France j'ai pas peur
tu rentrerais au stade Vélodrome bien
sûr rentrer ça va
alors on va maintenant passer à ton à
ton avenir
ton contrat avec Valenciennes se termine
à la fin du mois de juin donc à partir
de la fin du mois de juin tu es au
chômage tu as une idée quel club va
t'embaucher l'année prochaine c'est pas
ça me paraît difficile c'est vrai que en
réfléchissant un petit peu bon
vu que les dirigeants du football
français ont montré pour l'instant au
niveau de la solidarité je crois que ça
quand même sanctionné durement
bernes qui est
radié à vie tapis et l'OM qui rétrogradé
en seconde division quand même c'est
vrai mais je crois que c'est ça va être
difficile pour moi de trouver un club
dans la mesure où est-ce qu'un président
est un entraîneur de club si sportive
moi ils ont envie que je joue dans leur
équipe vont prendre le risque justement
de de faire subir à leur équipe à
travers moi des sifflets et puis bon des
problèmes qu'ils ont pas envie de ils
vont pas engager un joueur toutes les 5
minutes quoi ils sont habitués aussi
[Applaudissements]
oui tu as dit à valeur égale entre un
autre joueur et moi on prendra toujours
l'autre sûrement je pense que faudra le
demander au Président je sais pas tu as
flingué ta carrière un peu quand même
bah sûrement oui sûrement mais c'est pas
grave au moment où tu as décidé de
raconter ce dont tu avais été témoin à
tes dirigeants tu savais que tu
flinguais ta carrière
j'en sais rien je sais pas que je savais
pas que les gens allaient réagir de la
sorte mais bon je savais très bien que
que les gens ont peur je sais pas
pourquoi ils ont peur de parler et on
arrête je crois qu'on a toujours peur de
la vérité et c'est pour moi c'est triste
pour moi c'est triste si tu l'avais su
tu aurais parlé quand même je regrette
pas ce que ce que j'ai fait et je si ça
se reproduisait je le referai et j'ai
aucun regret est-ce que tu risques
d'arrêter le foot moi je crois que si
dans un voire deux mois j'ai pas de club
je crois que je vais être obligé de
d'arrêter le foot ou bon de partir à
l'étranger je sais pas au Canada par
exemple au Canada ou n'importe où là où
on voudra de moi si tu restes en France
t'as pas peur un jour parce que tu as
l'air assez solide quand même mais de à
force d'être sifflé d'être rué comme ça
de complètement disjoncter sur un stade
je crois que j'en ai eu l'occasion
souvent cette année surtout que ça a pas
très bien marché au niveau sportif avec
Valenciennes mais je crois que je me
suis bien maîtrisé pour l'instant et
puis j'espère que dans l'avenir ça va se
passer de la même façon et quand il joue
il est avec toi lui toujours maintenant
en conclusion tu as découvert que
dénoncé une magouille dans la France
d'aujourd'hui c'était plus grave que de
la faire
moi je dis qu'on marche sur la tête
parce que comme vous le dites très
justement la dénonciation de la
magouille devient plus grave que la
magouille je voudrais porter un petit
correctif Thierry est-ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est pas trois personnes
qui ont entendu Bernay C4 et parmi les
quatre personnes il y a de lit qui
appartient à l'équipe de l'Olympique de
Marseille et puis je veux dire aussi à
tous ceux qui a que Jacques Glassman
doit être une balance que c'est jamais
que la troisième fois que l'Olympique de
Marseille se retrouve dans cette
situation car les instances du football
ont eu à connaître à deux reprises de
magouille de cette nature et à deux
reprises les agissements des dirigeants
de l'Olympique de Marseille ont été
fustigés
pointe à la ligne résultat des courses
il est une balance
téléphone tout ce que l'on peut entendre
et l'autre se fait acclamer par 20 000
spectateurs en tournant autour du stade
Vélodrome des joueurs de Marseille qui
l'ont fait faire le regard moi je dis
des conneries c'est tout
ben écoute on va faire ce que peut-être
tu espérerais qu'on fasse de temps en
temps comme tu es sur un terrain et que
tu entends tout le monde qui hurle on va
te dématérialiser et vous aussi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu